uh because i have a little extra time i
have some uh i want to call fun
questions but we'll see if you think
they're fun in about a second um
you're from you definitely worked in the
theater and i'm curious if you have a
favorite place to uh to act in like your
favorite theater and what's your
favorite place to actually watch your
performance
ooh
i think my favorite place that i
performed
in the theater so far is the national
theatre in london
because it has a kind of anti-theatre
layout so the audience feel really close
when you're on the stage but when you're
an audience member watching the space
feels huge and so you get the epic feel
of the production that you're watching
um but it can still feel intimate as an
actor which is really nice so you don't
feel like you have to stretch so far to
reach everyone
so that's probably my favorite place to
perform and to watch
um
but i do also like smaller theaters as
well because then everything's super up
close you know and you feel that you can
you can get proper access to the access
in the story rather than feeling like
you're miles away
um have you still are you still
recovering from the game of thrones
unaired pilot pilot thing not going have
you gotten over it or is it still like a
little bit like man that i wish that had
gone
you know
i for myself personally i'm over it
because i try not to hold on to these
things too much i think it's important
as an actor to learn to be able to throw
things away because
there's so much flux um in our industry
particularly just you know being any
kind of freelance artist there's lots of
flux
um
i'm i felt sad because i felt like the
the story that jane goldman had written
had some real potential and i was really
excited to see what was going to happen
with it um and as a game of thrones fan
i felt like it was a really ambitious
take
on the world
um
but you know i've i've moved on there's
stuff's happened since so it's cool okay
i can pass it on
yeah you've landed on your feet i'm also
a big fan of jane's writing i was very
disappointed um but jumping into bruised
what was it about this character in this
script that said oh i want to do this
well when i read it um i
i found bobby buddha khan to be quite
mysterious there's not lots of
information about her in the script
which is always really intriguing
because
you know that can be one of two things
either the parts underwritten
or the parts leaving you lots of face to
um
you know fill in the blanks and and and
you know figure out for yourself what
that mystery is about and then make a
decision about whether how how clear
that is to the audience or not you know
how much you wear that on the surface or
not
um so i felt like there was lots of
scope with this character and i was also
just really excited to be in a film
about um female fighters you know i was
like oh i haven't really seen something
like this before
um you know so to be a part of that
world was really cool and then the added
factor of being able to be british in it
which was something that kind of came by
accident but really made sense once we
decided on it was also a nice thing to
be able to do
uh halle berry uh
it's it this is very ambitious for her
directorial debut she's starring it's an
mma role it's i mean it's just like
she bit off so much and think i mean it
uh what was it like watching her uh do
this because this is like she really
went for it with this you know
everything about this
oh yeah it was it was amazing and you
know people say the term life changing
often and they kind of throw it around
in a way that i think is a bit flippant
but i really mean it you know to watch
somebody like halle berry
who
for my whole life has felt kind of you
know inaccessible in the sense that
that's that's halle berry she's got this
kind of huge
label around her and she's the only
black female
uh to win oscar for best actress so far
and you know she's it was a part of my
childhood when i was watching film
growing up
um
and i was watching her
both in her element and in new territory
at the same time you know a very
experienced actress but also somebody
who is embarking upon a new project as a
director and then doing those two things
simultaneously and then doing her own
stunts you know and
she worked so hard um it was
it was incredible to see her tenacity to
see her work ethic and to see the the
grace with which she handled it was just
it was so wonderful so i really took a
lot from that as somebody who wants to
try and do
you know not just acting but other
different things as well i took so much
from that experience
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies and tv
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of bruised or
um you know if you have any really cool
behind-the-scenes stories you'd like to
share
i think what was what was so lovely
about not so much surprising but so
lovely about the project was that hallie
really wanted to feature new jersey you
know and the actual community of new
jersey and really get an essence of
the spirit of the place into the film so
that it wasn't just a kind of ambiguous
location where we were filming because
it looked right for the for the picture
um
and i remember
one day you know our trailers were at
one point on the side of the road and
hallie was walking out to go to set and
there was a lady driving a school bus
and she stopped and she let out the
window and she was like oh my god is
that the halle berry movie
and harley turned around and was like
yeah was like oh my god and all these
kids were in the back like didn't know
what was going on um and i found that
really kind of endearing you know seeing
this sort of
you know hollywood and the local
community kind of crashing together in a
really sort of beautiful way so i really
enjoyed that part of it
i would imagine you watched mma fights
and learned about the mma prior to
making the film was there anything that
you learned while researching this role
that really surprised you or were you
you wanted to sort of take with you
yeah i think i mean firstly you know
just watching mma is is kind of
incredible because there's a real
brutality to the sport but it's also
really
beautiful and i mean when i was watching
um
valentino warming up you know in in the
cage on set i just was like i do not
want to be anywhere near those kicks
like wow you know and they were just
warm-up kicks um and there's somebody
who's done a little bit of you know sort
of basic kickboxing myself i was so in
awe of the
sportsmanship and the athleticism of
these people um but also hearing their
stories you know was a big part of it
for me because i
i don't fight that much in the film at
all really i'm you know that's not my
role in the film so for me it was really
important to understand who these people
are who these women are and how they've
got there um and you know the stories
that they bring with them
into the cage you know um what they're
fighting for and and who they are as
people um
that was a really really important part
of it for me because the story isn't
just about fighting in in the kind of
physical sense you know it's got so much
more to it um so yeah that was a huge
part of the learning process for me
and that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say really enjoyed your work in
this i wish you nothing but the best and
i hope the film's a huge hit thank you
for your time
thank you steven